yeah hello and welcome to this video
thing paranoid from the UK trade six
games again so that's a bit surprised me
I mean I was kind of sure that I've
played them before word six games with a
lot yeah and even though we at the
beginning of all this I kind of have
forgotten again how it works how does
that work again this we should be tool
26 young lady success
I immediately captured okay so the Queen
a six is definitely a move let's do it
yeah taking us okay but letting him take
probably as well I mean you cannot care
for some I mean okay now we can but it
not with the Queen's on the board this
is not so easy for why to coordinate
this is the reason why the Bangko is
really good in blitz chess you have
usually the easier game with black
somehow because y has to coordinate his
claim and it's often simply not so easy
to do even though and why it might be
okay objectively speaking it's not easy
to do so um a couple of things here I
wonder where to go with this night 495
but I think he has better in that she
was not quite quite clear what this does
yellow light the front nine to five
becomes an option for for white one
thing I need to avoid is to to get the
position or let the position become
completely static if he goes night
before I go see for here i was thinking
or is there a trick and see it at the
moment so i do it
the back rank is a bit weak this is a
little bit cold it's a little bit
worrisome yeah i think i'm getting the
porn back and the question is before
then weakness that i can also put under
pressure or does he have something here
to actually exploit my my mentioned back
rank issue ya hear ting f8 is that a
move that looks looks shaky I don't want
to play a six quite clearly
at king of eight I mean I know it scary
or not but is it working is there some
problem or not I don't see it at the
moment so I'm playing this if you move
yeah yeah I can go back to see for I
think I don't have a tactic based on his
weak back going so I go here which will
attack me for and ce4 is still under
fire now that looks fine I can take see
for now my rokea is protected by the d7
light this is quite important activity
activity is very good here
yeah so i think i will take then look it
a tool so what's going on here yeah he
probably is active enough to keep it
equal probably this is maybe and then
move that ought to deform maybe okay my
main ideas to play a six and give me
some more space for the king
it probably is just equal
five mini to try to undermine d5 tiny
money
now I threatened to take and play with
reform reunite f6 should be good I do
this when you've got five
because you have two more or less what's
the point has to take on at six and then
we before King e5 he had rupee seven but
I'm still are a bit of a nuisance here
to him because of the group on the
second rank so I'm trying to push the
pawn
57 I don't don't quite invader think
it's 23 and idea g3 and then bring me
look there may be cooked rare form check
check check check check check I go to
the only square to blunder the look come
on oh it didn't take it check check
check why forfeit hometown wow good
absolutely nothing left here yeah I mean
okay it was six seconds or can do stuff
happens how can he do that i stumped
little here the only move that really
blah no tsurugi just III or something
and and here I just landed it way and it
doesn't take it now can yeah i think
with the game unreasonably reasonably
happy words i think fairly good on
standard bank oh yeah this is the formal
he doesn't get the blockade of c-4 going
slow
this is I think always enough clay and
black tends to be a little bit more
comfortable in those positions so I
missed some stuff here look a four or
stronger keeping more pressure against
him okay flow the engine wants to play
Bishop e3 and give away the pawn
immediately I'm not quite sure what I'm
threatening here I ok hi I'm threatening
ok five trapping the pitcher of the
night Wow Maya detect very strong now I
wasn't aware of the red yellow well here
I've got this slide symbolic advantage
here it was getting getting more serious
slowly making headway now whilst vice is
lost but ok well six seconds I'll I was
just too slow check can stumble into
that nozzle group I can just take g2 as
well and this is like this has helped
made character yeah that's the only move
that loser oak rly probably check and
you didn't take it come on five seconds
we made a million move crazy ok guys
thanks for watching